foreign
Providence Rhode Island what's up Haley
hi can you hear me with Crystal Clarity
what's up
okay thank you for taking my
really grateful for both your work
um okay Mike
will remain in a house but our budget
would be like razor thin for the next 12
to 15 years
so here's my question you absolutely a
hundred percent know the answer to that
so what is the thing going on inside
your soul that makes
coming to that realization and then
doing what you have to do so challenging
um so the challenge is at the market is
so uncertain and I don't think that we
could take a leap to us we would want to
downsize the size and the scale of our
home but it doesn't seem like the
numbers are making sense
um
so what's your take home
okay so our take-home pay is about 110.
my husband has a handyman business on
the side all right so there's there's
sometimes we can make more okay and
what's your mortgage
okay so the mortgage is 2500 right now a
thousand dollars of it is covered by my
mom I've been her caretaker
um we built her an in-law and she's
getting she's declining she needs a
facility care
and we don't feel comfortable without
her rent
covering this like the size the
utilities the upkeep of the house well
based on what you told me your mortgage
is about 27 of your take-home pay
yeah the numbers here don't scream fire
to me so where is the actual problem do
you guys have other piles of debt
hanging around
we uh we just have my car which we're
working on paying off but
um I guess where I'm I'm at is that the
amount of like replacing the deck
replacing the windows that number for us
is takes away from like
time with our family to cover
feel like we're too thin well those are
one-time repairs that we can do over a
period of time
that's not a monthly expense
so if we just set a small sinking fund
let's say you know 400 bucks a month
that's about five grand a year goes to
towards home repairs
would that solve this problem
um
I just feel like there's other pieces
here because you guys make 10 grand a
month yeah there's something your
mortgage 2500. 7 500 going
do you just want to not live in this
house anymore
my good those are good weeks of handyman
stuff that's those are those are when
all the stars align listen listen listen
listen
sure you don't need any permission to
leave to move
okay so how do we know where we're gonna
go go rent a house go rent a house
what's the fears underneath all this
what's wrong with you going to rent
somewhere for a year
um so if we were to run it would be
about the same price point that we're
paying now
but you have no big issue was that you
don't want to do all the repairs and
you're paying for all these things and
it's stressing you guys out
you're describing to us a pot of boiling
water and you're in it and we're telling
you to jump out and you're like yeah but
it's hot over there and it's cold over
there and so we're like you're painting
this picture that you can't win and I I
just don't buy it there's there's got to
be another solution it's not going to be
a comfortable one but there's got to be
a solution you just you just circle the
wagons on yourself and you have nowhere
to go
right yeah that's where yeah
I think you guys need to do a written
monthly budget and you need to figure
out what your low months are what your
normal months are what your high months
are and start planning for those low
months and everything that's gravy on
top we can set aside you have an
emergency fund right now
we do we have three months okay so that
should give you a level of peace that if
something goes down we have an emergency
fund to cover it and so I want you to
get away from this razor thin mentality
where there could be one thing that just
takes us out because that is stressful
that's going to keep you up at night and
let me tell you this it's not uncommon
when someone you love is hurting and
struggling
and you are seeing end of life
transitions happen right before you
you're a part of them it's almost
surreal the decisions you're having to
make the conversations you're having
um the documents you're signing and
when we do that on a foundation of chaos
when you and your husband aren't aligned
or your kids aren't and you aren't
connected or you're worried about your
finances or this house just has some
some
some memories in it that you're ready to
move on from
your body will just start sounding the
alarms and it's going to make everything
around you feel like it's the end of the
world you're going to feel pegged into a
corner boxed into a corner that you
can't get out of and it's just simply
not true you just got to turn the lights
on
and so some of this is going to be
solved by you sitting down and grieving
the fact
that your mom's moving from your home
possibly to or her last place
that she's ever going to live
and that stinks and it's hard and it's
heartbreaking and it's sad and it's
something to be grieved
and you and your husband may have had a
cool house and y'all had all these
dreams of fixing it up and doing it all
nice and it's just become a nightmare
even though financially it works out
that's all that's okay
but just grieve that we had this picture
in our head we thought it was gonna be
this and now it's gonna be something
else
and I'll tell you the year me and my
wife sold our house I actually had to
bring a check to closing because we sold
it at a loss
and we moved into a a dorm a two-bedroom
apartment with a toddler
just to let the Smoke Clear to pay our
debts off and to recalibrate our
marriage and our life and all that stuff
it's the best year we it's the best
investment we ever made it changed our
life in a bunch of different ways it
revealed some chaos that has taken years
to um to heal from but it was worth it
and for others just running from your
house great your problems and your
challenges and your grief is going to go
with you so that may not be the solution
here but it sounds like you're just
circling these challenges instead of
sitting on a kitchen table with your
husband and a yellow pad and a pen and
just saying we've got a we can't run
from these storms we can't run from the
smoke we gotta head straight in
does that sound right
yeah that sounds right
Haley hang on the line I'm going to send
you our every dollar budgeting app it's
going to help you make a plan for these
dollars I'm selling the car before I
sell the house and if that doesn't give
you enough margin then we can consider
our next move but I think John's right
this isn't a financial question this is
largely emotional and relational and
we're cheering you on either way